but i think by the end of the honeymoon
we really started to feel like a married
couple
but the good kind like on tv not like my
parents
you're not a real married couple until
you can pee with the door open and she's
okay with it
i told you i'm not okay with it
she loves
so
we got everybody gift
did you forget about us until you were
at the airport
no
we forgot about you until we were on the
plane
luckily there was wi-fi and i have
amazon prime
i heart new york ah the baby's gonna
love throwing up on this
look it doesn't have to just be new york
that's the beauty of it the initials in
y can stand for anything you like for
instance i understand that there is an
elderly rock and roll musician named
neil young perhaps you heard him
or if not him egyptian table tennis
silver medalist no ha yasri
or nana yamaguchi the japanese voice
actress who starred in sally the witch
did you just google the initials and why
i had wi-fi and a long plane fly draw
your own conclusions
oh guys that was very very thoughtful of
you
just give me a double xl
i told you you were right dear
[Music]
sheldon that's not how you write a thank
you card
what's wrong with it
dear aunt helen thank you so much for
the lovely place setting if my
handwriting looks strained that is
because this is the 16th thank you card
amy has forced me to write
the muscles in my wrist are cramping as
i struggle to finish this sentence
ow ow owed the pain love sheldon
fine
and amy
ow
this one is from leonard and penny
oh
the perfect gift for the perfect couple
oh save that card we need to throw it
back in their faces
i wonder what it could be oh it could be
anything a flute a letter opener no one
of those pins where you put the bikini
back on the naked lady
oh
isn't this nice
what is it
you know it's uh it's one of those
nope doesn't do that
oh maybe it's candy lick it
i don't wanna lick it you lick it
i'm not gonna lick it i just brush my
teeth
is it from one of your dumb sci-fi shows
none of the sci-fi shows i watch are
dumb sheldon okay westworld
but this has nothing to do with that
show other than it's also inexplicable
well leonard and penny are our best
friends they know us better than anyone
they said it's the perfect gift we must
be missing something
you don't
think it's a
marital aid do you
why don't be silly amy how is this big
glass shaft going to aid our marriage
oh leonard thank you again we love the
gift
do you know what it is no not even close
he thinks it's a clue to a scavenger
hunt
[Laughter]
so so happy
what is it what did you give them oh
it's just this dumb crystal wand that
howard and bernadette gave us for our
wedding penny and i made each other
miserable trying to figure out what it
was and we thought
why not pass that fun along to sheldon
and amy
wait a minute
did you give them the crystal chakra one
that i gave you for your wedding
yeah that's exactly what we did
you said you liked it yeah that's
exactly what i said
let the truth be revealed
[Music]